[Music] Well, from the
moment
bad
news is announced, even if it's totally
objective and it actually happens,
it's much more practical to just huddle together,
much more
reassuring. And today we live in a
generalized denial with people
telling you, "No, everything's fine," because it's much
easier to hear, because it's
much more comfortable, because it does
n't shake things up. And then, well,
until the day things go wrong,
because they inevitably will,
unfortunately. Today there's no way
out without pain. When you do something stupid,
you pay for it sooner or later.
When you go on a bender at
a big restaurant and eat
like a pig, well, in the
end they bring you a bill, you
have to pay it. Well, it's
exactly the same here. We lived on credit
for years, we took
full advantage of it, we had growth,
we had everything, everything was going very well,
and now we have to
Now we have to come back down to earth and settle the bill.
I'm not saying it's
the end of the world, it's not a
question of survivalism or anything like that.
I'm not telling people to
bury themselves in a bunker with
a submachine gun, it has
nothing to do with that. I'm simply saying we've
made a number of stupid mistakes, which have been made
worse by the actions
of central bankers and
economic and political authorities who,
as usual, didn't see it coming and
managed things in the
worst possible way. So, there comes
a time when we'll have to pay
the price, that's all I'm saying. The longer
we wait to pay, the more we
postpone the deadlines, the more we try to avoid it, the more we make things worse,
and therefore the more
it's going to hurt. That's all. Now, it's
a message that people don't like to
hear because it bothers them,
because it disturbs their very
often unwavering
certainty.  I would simply tell them, read
a little bit, look at what has happened
elsewhere,
and you will conclude that, indeed, things can't go well. Then, are there
solutions we haven't thought of? I
'm not sure, because
unfortunately, we've reached such a
point of no return, and it's
widespread today. That is to say,
we don't have the possibility of having a
historical reference point since it has never
happened at this level before. Well,
today we're navigating a bit blindly. The
only thing we're sure of is that it can't be
resolved
without pain. So, whether people like it or not, whether there are
people who
think I'm taking advantage of the situation, etc., that's their business.
Often
their arguments are quite weak. Well,
when I
say this, I don't have much
to sell. I'm simply saying there are
a number of things. You have to
be factual.  I'm ready to
provide all the figures that prove what
I'm saying. I have no problem with that. You have to
be factual, and when there are
things that
mathematically cannot go back
without being settled
first, you
are unfortunately forced to... to... to... to
anticipate certain things, and some
things that aren't necessarily going to be fun.
Normally,
you had monetary creation
that was correlated, if you will, to
global growth, okay, the
growth of trade, and so on. So we
obviously needed to create
money. Now, creating money is
n't creating banknotes; it's creating debt. It's a whole
bunch of things; it's
not simply banknotes, grandpa. So,
normally, you had
global growth that was around 34, and you had growth in the
global money supply that was also 34,
which was
normal. Today, you are in a
situation where you have
global growth that is rather close to zero,
and you have
growth in the money supply
that is rather around...  17-18% so we
see that there is already a discrepancy which no
longer fits if you have something
which is no longer based on anything, like
paper money, what is it?
I take you a sheet of paper,
I write a number on it, if you
trust me, I have written
€100, it is worth €100.  If the guy across from me is
selling me goods and he
believes in this note that he trusts the one he loves,
it's worth €100.  The
day he loses confidence, what's it worth? It's worth
zero, okay? It's worth zero because
it's barely worth the price of paper. If
your currency is no longer based on anything, no longer
based on gold, it's no longer based
on anything, neither on growth nor on the [unclear] of a
country, what is it worth? Nothing the
day people lose confidence, the
day I hand you a bill and you
say, "Oh yeah, but no, your stuff is
worthless, I don't want to take it." At
that moment, it's worth
zero. It's exactly like if tomorrow
you take all the bills from your
Monopoly set. It's the same, there's a
number printed on them, okay?
You go out and try to buy
a car with them. If the guy in
front of you isn't a complete idiot,
he'll tell you, "Sir, these are
Monopoly bills, they're worthless." What
he doesn't realize is that
today, the
dollar, yen, and euro bills are
Monopoly bills, so they only last
until the day a country or a [unclear]  An
economic commentator said, "Ah yes, but
I don't recognize this bill as
having a value of 100, 500, or 50
euros. I say it has no
value from that point on; it
collapses. So this system—it was
Voltaire who said
this in the
18th century, 1729 I think—Voltaire's statement on this, which is that
a currency
based on
trust in the one who loved it, so that's what
today, that's what's
the case, will
invariably return to its
original value, which is zero. So
today we still have trust, but
for how long, I don't know.
But there comes a point when you create
something out of nothing, and well, inevitably
you fall flat on your face. Why is that?
We see it clearly with
the famous game of Monopoly. It's an
interesting parallel because
if the
banker gives you more money, you
never stop playing Monopoly by
definition."  If every time you
need to replenish your savings, the
banker gives you money, the
monopoly game never stops.
So, regarding raw materials, what you need to
understand is that today,
monetary policies are responsible for
a good part of the rise in
raw material prices, especially
food. That is to say, what we
called the Arab Spring didn't just happen.
The
Arab Spring wasn't a sudden rise in
population realizing they were
ruled by
dictatorships. They had been
ruled by dictatorships for 40 years; they did
n't all wake up together on the same
day. So what does that mean? It means that, to a
large extent, if you
look at where it started, it
often started in the south of the country, and it was
people who had nothing to eat. And
why did they have nothing to eat?
Simply because the prices of
raw materials and food had
skyrocketed. And why did they expose themselves?
And that's...  Interesting, because
Mr. Bernan was
there. You only have to look at the number of
commodity futures contracts
to realize that it's
largely, very largely, due to
Mr. Bernan's policy. When
he announced his first round of quantitative
easing, the number of commodity futures contracts
increased a
thousandfold, and with the second round, it
increased tenfold. So, I'm happy for
Mr. Bernan to tell us
that he's absolutely not responsible for
the rise in commodity prices, but still, there's
a curious
coincidence, if you can call it that. So, there really is
a link
between this
monetary policy and the rise in
commodity prices, and also the rise in the
price of oil and therefore
energy.
So, this gentleman should stop
this quantitative easing because it's going to
lead us slowly to our downfall.
[Music]
All the pensions... well, we won't have pensions,
I think that's clear.
Pensions... well, we've known that for a long time.
It's not a surprise,
uh, there won't be any, but if only
retirees were affected, that would be, that would still be,
that would still be good, but
unfortunately everyone is going to suffer.
Why is everyone going to suffer?
Well, because there comes a point
where, unfortunately, you can no longer
afford to pay pensions on a pay-as-you-go basis
because you have more retirees
than
working people. So the equation is pretty simple. So what does that mean? It
means that, unfortunately, the
pension system will
collapse. You know, we had also created a
small
supplementary fund to pay for pensions.
It was well invested by
people, by the elite of our society. It
was well invested in stocks, and
obviously, in 2008, these stocks
took a hit, in 2011
they took another hit,
and we're not likely to see the
prices recover anytime soon. So we started by losing a
lot of money on them. I'm not
sure they're good for anything.  So,
this fund, there you have it. You're in the same boat
today anyway,
but not simply, I'm telling you, retirees,
all savers are going to
suffer. Why? Why did they
raise the interest rate on the Livret A savings account? It's
not to
give you money, it's not to
give you 175% interest. It's
simply because it allows the
state to nationalize savings. So
they nationalized savings. The
French, who are always happy to be taken care of,
rushed into the Livret A. And why did they do
that? Well, quite simply because
in 2013, imagine,
France will be the
biggest issuer of debt in Europe, and they
had to find someone to
buy these damn OATs (French government bonds), and so, the
government bonds. And well, there you have it,
they found the
perfect sucker: the one who went into the
Livret A. And then at one point or
another...  I'm telling you, either through default or
hyperinflation, your book will be worth nothing.
There you go, and thank you, move along. There's nothing
to
see here. It's an equation that's
mathematically complicated to
solve. No, but the problem is that
you've gone too far. We've
passed the N-turn point, so there comes
a point where, whatever you do, you let it go.
American method, okay? The
Americans decided that there was
absolutely no question of making the
slightest effort, so they let it go,
and then, come what may, we'll see what
happens. Uh, the Japanese are the same,
same policy. In Europe, I
told you, the Germans are
terrified because they know what's going to happen,
and so they don't want to
relive
that. But in the meantime, we've chosen, for now,
another path, which is to say
we're going to save money. But the
problem, what people forget, is that
today, and yesterday too, it was the same. Who took over? Who...  What
drove
growth in these countries was government
spending, it was
salaries paid by
the state. It wasn't the private sector that
ultimately brought about growth,
so it was largely the state.
And when the state can no longer, when
the state runs out of money, well, that's it,
you no longer have
growth. So what happens today?
Well, you have
the state that runs out of money and says, "Well, we're going to make
savings." Actually, it's not so much
savings that are being made; it's more that they're
taking a little
more from us. So they're cutting
pensions, they're cutting salaries, they're cutting everything. Yes,
but the problem is that it's
too late.
Today, these policies are
obviously recessionary because if
you cut salaries in half, you ca
n't imagine that people are going to
consume like crazy. So it's...
Obviously, with
recessionary policies, when you
have a recession, well,
your debt burden is at, I don't
know, 5
% today in Spain. Spaniards
are indebted. If you count the
debt on
real estate, you're well over
%. So that means it costs you at
least 5%. If you don't have 5%
GDP growth, you can't pay
the interest. We agree on that, right? So
it's very simple:
today, nobody is able to
pay the interest on the debt. What does that mean? It means
that everyone
borrows month after month to pay the
interest on the debt. So your debt
increases. And when you have a
really negative GDP, well, you have to
borrow even more to
pay the budgets, and so on.
That means that at some point, your debt
will continue to increase. What will
happen? The markets will start
asking questions about the
possibility of repaying
this debt, and at a
certain point...  The markets are saying, "
I'm not going to get repaid," so the
cost of the
interest rates—what is it? It's the
price demanded
to cover this risk of non-
repayment. So, at that point, these interest rates start
to
increase, and it becomes more and more
difficult to pay the interest on
the debt. And so, there you have it, you've
entered a kind of
vicious cycle, a snake biting its own
tail. You can save
as much as you want, but if
you do, it weighs on the GDP.
If the GDP is negative, then you can't pay the
interest on the debt, and therefore you can't
repay your debt. And so
your debt continues to increase year after year, and so on. And so, there you have it.
Well, after that,
you have people who have very simplistic solutions. They tell you, "Well, he just shouldn't repay the famous 'Yaka,' right?" So, you have people who
have very simplistic solutions. They
tell you, "Well, he just has to not repay
the famous 'Yaka,' right?"  Well,
if we don't repay,
yes, okay, so all the savers
are ruined, right? Because people
don't do the math. They say, "Yes, but
anyway, there are rich people." No, there aren't only rich people.
The Livret A savings account is a savings account,
and it's not just for
rich people. All the banking products
you
have are savings, okay?
And what is this savings invested in?
Bonds. If you do
n't repay them, well, that's it, you
have no savings left. So we have to
stop coming up with solutions
like that, which aren't solutions at all.
You
hear people saying, "Oh well, anyway,
the ECB just has to issue
bonds without interest rates." Oh yes,
who's going to buy them? Okay. And then
next to that, you have the same
person telling you, "Anyway, it's
very simple, they just have to not pay any
interest rates." And the
returns...  What about your investments?
If there's a return on an
investment, it's because there's an
interest rate somewhere.
So it's appalling nonsense, that's just how it is. So, we don't care about rating agencies. It's
terrifying, these rating agencies. It makes me laugh, though, that
you have
people,
bankers, who pay
rating agencies to know what to
think, as if they couldn't
think for themselves. And
you have
rating agencies telling them what to
think, often three steps
behind, you know? I mean, I didn't
wait for Standard & Poor's
and Moody's to tell me that Greece wouldn't
repay to know that Greece would never
repay. And I find it
sad that bankers
and
economic authorities wait for Standard
& Poor's to tell them what to think about
Greece. So, I think it's
not very useful, except maybe for...
Giving
exorbitant salaries to a few
analysts, otherwise we wouldn't have a
job, but that's all. It's
pointless. I buy
corporate bonds every day; I don't need to know
the Standard & Poor's rating to
know that if I buy a
2-year Farge bond,
Farge will repay me, that's a
certainty. I don't need to know its
rating; I couldn't care less.
So I'd say, learn to think for
yourself. It'll save you from being
dependent on the Standard & Poor's rating. You have to realize
that today, countries that we
know perfectly well will
never repay their debts, like Japan, are
still rated A or less, or
whatever. Basically, if
you want, they're still rated 17/20. That's pretty much the bottom of the
rating agencies' scale. It's just...  It's
grotesque, especially since we know they won't pay back,
so we have to stop. There comes
a point
where, frankly, learn to think for
yourselves. That will be much, much
more interesting.
Now
they're being sanctioned
by the United States, which is extremely displeasing to be subjected
to
this degraded fairy tale. Well, we continue down this
ridiculous path.
Today, the American government
should be happy; it's not yet at
triple-C, so it should be happy.
And we have to stop this
circus with the rating agencies.
They've completely failed.
We saw it with subprime mortgages; all the
subprime products were rated triple-A. Anyway,
we see that it's nonsense; it means
nothing. So, it's
impunity for
all politicians, right?
You're not going to put
Mr. Bernan in prison when he
deserves it a hundred times over because he's
sinking his country.
The global economy, except he'll
never go to
prison. You've never had a banker
face any
sanctions, and you won't have
the EFSF bankers facing
sanctions either. But it's not
surprising that we're where we are today; it's
because there are never any sanctions, no
one is ever held accountable for anything.
So from that point on,
I don't see why people would
n't continue today. Have you
seen a banker who ended up in
jail because he lost
billions? Have you seen a banker who ended up
in jail with the
LIBOR scandal? No, never. So why
would you expect it to stop today?
You see, you had
a pretty monstrous warning in
2008. We almost all went under in 2008
with the mistakes of the...
We could have said, well, in a more or less
normal world, these people... they still...  They were really, really close to the finish line.
They're going to try to regulate a bit more,
they're going to try to take less
risk, and that's not it at all, not at all.
You look at the banks' balance sheets, uh,
for most of them they've
increased. BNP tells us that they've
reduced their
balance sheet, but they've reduced it by a lot. They
had a balance sheet that was over
2 trillion and now it's at
1930, I think. That's a huge effort, a huge
effort. And then during that time,
BNP's forward positions, so off-balance sheet, have gone
from 46 trillion to 48
trillion euros. Frankly, I don't see it, I don't see it. I still have
trouble seeing a reduction
in risk there. Well, maybe someone
will try to explain to me who has
more risk, but I'm having trouble. We
see the oldest Italian bank
and one of the oldest banks in the
world, Montpassan, which went bankrupt
last week or the week before.  I don't know anymore
because we suddenly discovered that, well, it wasn't all that great, that there were
CDSs everywhere
and that the risk had
collapsed. So don't tell us
today that the risk has
decreased, that the banks are
now in control, and
so on. They're not in control at all, and
the risk hasn't
decreased at all. I'm telling you, there's no
regulation in the banks, there's no
more control than before, there's no
more... They're throwing dust
in your eyes, telling you, "Okay,
now we've organized things," and
so on. They talk a lot about Tier 3
because that's supposed to add a
little more
capital, but the problem isn't
adding 1 or 2%
more capital. When you see
the positions, I told you, 48
trillion, it's not because you're going to
add 1% more to the Tier
1 ratio that...  Okay, that'll save the day,
and everything else stems from that too. In other
words, there's absolutely no
control. They're just stringing you along. Why? Well,
because when you want to organize
things, when you try to
control things, you go to the
bankers in 2008 who are
drowning, you hand them a
blank sheet of paper, you ask them to sign it, and then you
take care of putting things in
place. What did we do? We didn't do
that at all. We pulled them out of
the water, we dried them off, we gave them
free money, telling them to keep
playing with it, okay? So we fattened them up,
and then we say, "Listen
guys, if you don't mind, could we
organize ourselves to separate
banking activities from market activities?" What does
the banker say? He
tells you to get lost, with a
big smile, adding, "And if you
bother me, I won't lend to the economy anymore."
He lends  Not at all, but he made
the political authorities believe it, who then
said, "Oh no, my God, no, no, no, no, please don't do that,
keep
lending to the economy." Okay, fine, so you can just
throw away your stupid law, and then we'll just carry on with
our quiet little business. That's how it
works. And so, you absolutely don't have
any
real laws today that organize things and
actually prevent
things like 2008 from happening again,
because today they are
perfectly capable of happening again, and even more
seriously. As for
tax havens, I
would say it's a... it's a... it's a non-issue. We're stirring up trouble, we're stirring up trouble,
Switzerland, the good people... and meanwhile,
the Netherlands
continues, the Channel Islands continue,
Hong Kong continues, and so on
and so forth. So everyone has their own little
tax haven, and
then on the other side you have the...  The
French, the Germans, well, the
Europeans, who say, "Oh well, in
Switzerland it's not good," and meanwhile, they
continue with Ireland.
Ireland isn't a tax haven,
maybe Ireland with 12.5%
corporate tax
isn't a tax haven, but they
continue with Ireland, and on the other
hand, they crack down on
the 15 idiots who have an
account in a tax haven
like Switzerland or elsewhere, I don't know, that's
not the problem, the
large sums, the...  The
big, the big accounts of companies and
so on, they're not in
Switzerland, they're elsewhere,
so we're trying to bring them in there, even by
putting Ireland in
Europe. So it's just grotesque,
as usual, but well, it's just another
red herring
waved in front of you to make you think about something
else.
[Music] The point is to
cast doubt on
everything that's
consensual and on everything that comes out.
That is to say, today you should
n't take the figures as they come in, you should
n't take the
ideas as they come out, and you have to
try to confront them, to
challenge them, to see if they're
coherent, incoherent, and so on.
Today, this is a job that's
absolutely not being done. You have
traders in trading rooms
waiting for the employment figures, whether they're
better or worse than expected,
and
then they decide on a strategy based on
that.  They will never, at any point,
try to check if this figure is
consistent with other available data.
So, you have
economic data today that you don't have—
for example, try to find
the unemployment figures in Europe. Good luck! On the other hand,
you have countries that
actually publish their figures. In the
United States, they publish them, even if they
give you a manipulated figure.
Well, you just have to do a little
work, you just have to
look for it, you just have to
think a little bit,
and then you can
find the real figures.
So it's not very complicated.
You can also try this when they give
you
a growth figure, for
example, in China, where it's very
difficult to get statistics. But
you can try to think a little bit.
You look at the figure of 7.5
that comes out, and then you think, "Hey, that's
interesting because the Baltic
Dry Index, which is the
price of freight
between China and..."
Western shipping,
uh, it's curiously at its lowest point, it's
amusing. So if
growth ever returns, we'll
need ships to export, well, that's bad luck, it's at its lowest.
Then
you look at the
Chinese foreign trade figure and then you
look at the American import figure, and
you see that it just doesn't match, it's
amusing. So there's
one person in this story who's causing the problem, who is it? Is it
the United States or the
Chinese or both? Probably both. Uh,
you have a whole bunch of things
like that. We've looked at
electricity consumption too. They're
trying to make us believe they're doing
7.5% growth, and there's no
higher
electricity consumption. So something does
n't add up. Uh, we have a whole bunch of
correlations to
establish, and uh, we have to
try to be consistent. We
have to try  to find out, uh, if we're being fed
nonsense or if, uh, uh, there's
actually some
real basis for these figures. So, uh,
today we know very well—my
little quirk, because it always
amuses me so much because it's so
outrageous and so poorly done—it's
American unemployment.
American unemployment, uh, today we know very
well that it reduces the
working-age population and that the, the, the
drop in the unemployment rate is
solely due to that, not to anything else.
So there really is, and this is
purely common sense, too. It's not, uh, enough to
graduate from a prestigious
school; you simply need a little bit of
common sense. We're told the United
States is
reindustrializing, right? That is to say, bringing
industries back home
and starting to, to, to start
doing not just services, but manufacturing.
And then you look at the
number of good men who are
employed in industry, there are
They're not laying off workers, so I'm all for
reindustrialization, but I think there comes
a point where they'll have to hire
people. The same goes for
housing. They tell you the housing market has picked up in the
United States. Oh yeah, but it's funny,
they're not hiring anyone.
How do they build the houses? Do they
build themselves? Or are they
prefabricated houses and the
clients
build them? So there's
a real need for reflection
on the figures they're giving you.
We know very well about the
inflation figures they're giving you. I
mean, everyone does their shopping, everyone
knows that inflation isn't
1.5% in France. So it's
not very complicated. You have to
have a little bit of common sense
and a little bit of
reflection. It's true, you have to
work, it's not easy every
day, but there is  Design offices with
300 people, and these guys are
constantly spouting nonsense, they should make those
300 guys actually work, huh?